savate un départ de la 4e étape du
premier tour d'europe cycliste au yen à
waterloo
étape 3 198 km et à 286 km déjà quatre
hommes se sont échappés
la cena en quoi ton bidon et plus ne
pense pas combineront quoi j'ai soif
n'est plus si vous êtes tous seraient
même voulez pas vous chargez au départ
et après 50 km où taper les papin
comprend pasqua par spot aux bisons
enfin celui toi c'est pas dans mon
conjoint ce sont les anglais aux fins
combien de minutes qui sort les anglais
une minute 15 au dernier pointage
- 40 secondes et grave pour mettre le
paquet cambronne fighting wataru oui les
parents ont fait le forcing h 30 tarots
l'on inscrive dans les coupes 9 en fait
tout le boulot lci elle arrive à l'état
frais comme un gardon
excuse moi alors à lui le maillot jaune
à l'huile évocateur à l'huile et biblis
à lui les photos par angoua cambronne
bulles de savon sinon on comprendra
alors ferme là les pédales mais il faut
bien dans l'école mais sur le plateau se
répartir et forcément ils sont sur un
panier star tu t'es toute l'année
parfois mon bide en coin après je suis
ton bilan jeudi on a les engrais
derrière on s'est vraiment bien et asus
et wim van tinh et ramène les [ __ ]
ils nous rattrape
oh mais on les prend à pau on peut les
avoir comme on dit non on ne peut pas
partir sans les hordes de talleyrand
aujourd'hui bas-rhin moi j'en ai marre
des directeurs sportifs un loft en
espagnol en fin de course et il faut
attendre leur permission alors qu'on a
la victoire dans l'open napo ma poche
cela dit qu'on peut se les rattraper les
anglais devront enfin à potasser jamais
vu qu'on se fasse pas de parler d'envié
chez nous pas à combien on est très fair
lot 1 kg mais bon bah tant pis porte a
les reins on fonce la vidéo
tout effort ou alors dans sa taille mais
quoi senna pense moi ton bidon
tu dois être au mur ça va être coupé les
pattes
combien on est maintenant on n'est rien
de minutes sur 301 croiser moins
d'impôts devraient pousser la tactique
c'est moi laissez moi faire on peut pas
partir à 4 contre groupe signera au
chant et d'autre un marteau il est temps
que il a cassé son guidon et qu'on s'y
jouait dans le peloton
ça m'agace c'est qu'aujourd'hui un jeu
qu'un kilomètre avant waterloo et si on
est parfois mais la victoire facile
alors écoutez moi les petits arrivé à
waterloo
vous mettez en corée vous faites le mur
et moi je vous lâche à 200 mètres de la
ligne avant de nommer prénom alors si je
tenais au waterloo on se farcit le
classement par équipe vous serez bien
content au combat mais nous aussi on
aimerait bien voir le maillot de temps
en temps on n'est rien qu'une fois tu
peux pas me permettre de prendre des
risques c'est encore le tour de l'île
d'elbe al-farsi plus les six jours de
wagram et critérium de la bérézina du
coup je remporte le tout si je veux
avoir le championnat d'europe par points
alors rien à dire
senna parfois tombes dont j'ai le coup
de pompe
ça y est les gars waterloo on arrive au
vélodrome les maillots n'empêche même
passé sa roue et beltoise roussi alors
c'est pas bronché c'est un mois prochain
c'est plus cher mais plus chère et plus
le faire ici le vélodrome municipale de
waterloo dans ce plan d une assistance
rapport dans quelques instants vassaux
jugée l'arrivée de cete 4e étape du tour
d'europe cycliste mais voici les
coureurs à l'entrée du vélodrome en t2
comme napoléon plus ailleurs ce qui
n'est pas moins de murailles maseda et
c'est le départ du semi avant le tour
final haute est plus cher près d'alès
mais quoique bénavente ans aux biens
japonais ont fait le forcing le stif
merveilleux où l'on connaissait rien de
remonter
c'est leur pognon des années terribles
celle d'abolir du sacre la souplesse
dans les jambes cette admirable
voici la bcrg reconduit mais a proposé
de passer le mur à cambrai
je vous rappelle qu'on plante d'arriver
premier plus cher deuxième napoléon
troisième passer la muraille quand brad
pitt au but vide plus cher pour la
télévision lui surpris les plus sûres on
a fait ce qu'on a vu napo on a mis le
paquet le plus cher était en pleine
forme
t'en fais pas à montlieu pas gagnera
d'autres termes à waterloo
enfin les âges mais non ces points déjà
merci les gars vous êtes chouette plus
tard quand vous direz c'est un
interlocuteur peut pas un impôt tout est
le plus grandes telles plus fort au
maire de tana pourquoi se reprendre à
ton maillot riche et bien on cordonnière
à g et le tour d'europe pour moi c'est
râpé maintenant c'est plus car accroché
mon bureau dans tout plaisante tu veux
vraiment accroché oui définitivement
alors passons maintenant aux bidons